so were you a fan of the show prior to
joining the cast I have to be honest I
wouldn't say I was a fan of the show but
I was you know supportive of the show I
didn't watch the show in full episodes
but I knew enough of like you know what
pops up on YouTube Google feed you know
news Yahoo news stuff like that that
popped up and then like you know blogs
they report on the show so you know Shay
room and all these other Bravo shows
like you know I can get a gist of what's
going on awesome yeah that makes sense
do you did you have a strategy going in
like all right I'm about to be around
all these ladies did you come up with
things or were you just what you what
was your plan I went in I went in
blindsided and willy-nilly like I didn't
I didn't do enough research and I
remember Toyo was like you need to do
your research but like I just felt like
if I did I probably was not going to do
go into it so so um I just figured you
know I kind of took I kind of took it
like like me going being back in basic
training again I didn't know what I was
getting myself into but I just had to go
through it you know just to say I did it
you know because it was a one in
a-lifetime opportunity and um I just
decided to try it out I'm glad you did
because it's certainly it's been a fun
time watching you interact with these
ladies um when do you think the quad
comparisons will stop oh my gosh I think
they're always just going to be there
you know I think the's just going to be
there um but you know I know who I am I
know what I stand for and you know you
know I think that people are always
people are always GNA talk I'm never
gonna be able to shut them
up that's very true that's very true um
what do you have a relationship with
quad at all at this time or just no no
it's non-existent um but you know like I
I didn't really know her before the show
and I still kind of feel like I don't
know her but you know um but
she's probably probably within I don't
don't know I think that if you count on
all the conversations that we've had you
probably can say it was maybe a total of
like five minutes or something you know
what I'm saying like it it's not a lot
so it's just like I'm surprised that she
has a lot to say about me it's just like
okay I I don't know
her funny how that works isn't
it right right who are you closest to in
the cast I would say right now um I
really like Dr Simone Toya and Alicia
you know and fedra I talked to fedra too
I think me and fedra we do we do Vibe we
definitely Vibe being two southern girls
and we like the joke around you know I
think that she got a little country in
her that's like
me it's good to have a little country in
you right right
right speaking of um you know closeness
I know your relationship with Dr
Heavenly went left before the wedding um
where where do y'all stand now um me and
heav do not have a relationship I think
she's trolling me right now and you know
I don't even know why is for no reason
she actually sent me a text on her
birthday like two weeks ago it was like
I love you you're smart you're
intelligent remember I said that I'm
making you a star I'm like okay I didn't
respond like I just like it's just just
interesting and then she just she just
bashing me every day you know it's like
okay right this what it is you know to
be a star do I want
it yeah right you know I'm just like you
know I think that you know she can go
about things a different way and I think
that it's also a tactic that she's doing
like hazing me and I think that she uh
is trying to deviate from what's going
on in her own life Maybe maybe I don't
know that would make sense that would
make sense um let's get to the fun stuff
how is newly wed life treating you it is
great it's great to be able to come home
to someone that loves you wants you
around needs you and someone that's
affectionate funny you know it just it
feels great to just have a man and then
knowing that you're safe in his arms and
someone's going to provide for you
protect you it's the
bomb especially being by yourself for a
while and been seeing for a minute like
it feels good to have someone that got
your
back that's so wonderful I'm so happy
for you when did you know he was the one
well I knew that he was one when we
first met um the first we we first met
uh back in 2020 and we had a whole
weekend date we talked about marriage we
talked about love we talked about kids
um where we're going to live and all
that kind of stuff and you know
afterwards like Gregory just made me
feel comfortable being around in his
presence like it was kind of like a
familiar feeling where you know even if
you had that awkward silence like I just
felt comfortable being around him like
you know we're both twins you know maybe
has something to do with us just being
twins being in a wom with someone and um
he just made me feel so like warm and
comfortable and I knew when I got back
on that plane going back home this is it
this is the one this is my husband I
knew
it I love that I love that and you know
I think fedra said it really well you
know watching uh in the episode she said
you know Greg looks so happy he's the
happiest I've ever seen him he looks
settled and so I'm glad that y'all are
able to find that kind of love with each
other um now you made what I interpreted
to be a joke um about Mr uh Dr G's money
and some of those ladies ran with it
right um so what do you have to say to
the people who think you're only with
him for his money I think that
um it's funny because like I am one of
the in the top 10% of black women that
make six figures and um these women they
know that you know what I'm saying they
know that but I don't know maybe they
just wanted to run with it for whatever
reason for a storyline I guess to make
fun of me but um you know I had my own
resources I was a veteran in the Air
Force um I went on active duty I worked
in the intelligence field before moving
here um I'm all into philanthropy like
you know like they know my character and
it's just like funny that they just ran
with that and um you know but what's
wrong with uh have having your own
resources why not get more why not be
with your partner and you guys put your
resources together and you guys build on
that we're trying to have a family and
we we have talked about where we want to
go um building um generational wealth
for our kids why not get more together
you know what I'm saying so it's just
like you know I help Gregory in his
office at times I go and work at he
needs me you know it's just like these
women know my character so if you want
to call me a gold digger or a gold
digger go ahead it don't bother us we
know who we are good I love that yeah
stay true to yourselves don't block it
out just block it out
right um I do have one more question
because uh there are there was a lot of
talk I know you and Dr Heavenly had that
conversation about um how Dr G can
sometimes be controlling um what would
you say to the people because I know
some fans kind of agree with that um
what would you say to them about who
think they he that he is to controlling
well I was speaking to a specific
situation that I was upset about and
confiding in a friend I was confiding in
her and just sharing something plus we
were drinking so of course like at the
time like my feelings are a little
heightened at the moment you know what
I'm saying a lot of people say a lot of
things that they don't particularly mean
but they're just upset and um um you
know we are just learning about each
other and I think that whenever you're
in a relationship you're going to have
conflict you're going to have issues
it's just a matter of how you guys are
going to work through that conflict and
resolve those issues that's what
marriage is about and you know in our
relationship we don't move backward we
move forward beautiful awesome I'm glad
to hear that and I'm so happy for the
both of y'all looking forward to see
some babies on pop up on the show you
know we love a cute baby here I know
right oh my gosh when are you ready to
have a bun in the oven I'm ready now
we're actively trying and you know my
nephew he actually came out for the
summer so I was like babe this is gonna
be this is a test right here let's you
know let's get used to this and my
nephew he's three and he loves Uncle G
he Lov his tit and you know he was
giving us some run for of money I'm like
this is gonna be like our life you know
but we really enjoyed having my nephew
here for a week just spending time with
us and we are actively trying to have a
baby and we will be blessed with any
any any baby any whether it be bor or
girl that God will bless us with awesome
I well I'm hoping for the best for y'all
um thank you so much for taking the time
to chat with me today I really
appreciate
it thank you so
much